ابرز تطورات اليوم ما اعلنته كتائب القسام
من قصف تل ابيب الكبرى بالصواريخ ردا على
المجازر الاسرائيليه بحق المدنيين
الفلسطينيين وقد دوت صفارات الانذار في
مدينه تل ابيب الكبرى وعشرات المدن
الاسرائيليه في ضواحيها الجنوبيه والشرقيه
وادخلت ثلاثه ملايين اسرائيليه على الاقل
الى الملاجئ والغرف المحميه من جانبه قال
الجيش الاسرائيلي انه حتى وبعد 74 يوما من
الحرب ما زالت صفاره الانذار تدوي وسط
اسرائيل وما زال ملايين المواطنين يبحثون
عن
[موسيقى]
ملجا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
قلبه
نشير الى الخبر العاجل الذي يظهر على
شاشتنا الان نقلا عن مراسله الجزيره اذ
تقول ان صفارات الانذار تدوي في صوفه في
غلاف غزه الجنوبي في اللحظه الراهنه وهناك
عاجل اخر يظهر ايضا على شاشاتنا الان اذ
تقول كتائب القسام انها قصفت حشودا لجنود
العدو شرق رفح بقذائف هاون من العيار ثقيل
معنا من تل ابيب مراسل الجزيره الياس كرام
الياس كرام اذا
ا اذا هناك يوم يبدو عصيبا في تل ابيب اذ
تعرضت تل ابيب الكبرى لرشق صاروخيه عده من
كتائب القسام اجبرت وطبعا مناطق اخرى
اجبرت ثلاثه ملايين على الاقل من
الاسرائيليين الى الدخول في
الملاجئ بالفعل محمود هو يوم عصيب ويدل
على ان الجيش الاسرائيلي في مازق كبير
وكذلك المستوى السياسي في اسرائيل لانه
بعد 74 يوما من عمر هذه الحرب المقاومه
الفلسطينيه ما زالت قادره على ضرب منطقه
تل ابيب الكبرى المدينه والمدن الكبرى في
ضواحيها الجنوبيه والشرقيه حتى ان
المنظومه التي تدخلت في اعتراض هذه
الصواريخ لم تكن فقط منظومه القبه
الحديديه انما منظومه مقلاع دهود المخصصه
لاعتراض صواريخ بعيده المدى التي يبلغ
مداها نحو 120 الى 140 كيلومترا وهذا ربما
يحمل في طياته مؤشرا على ان بعض هذه
الصواريخ التي كانت موجهه صوب وسطي ومركزي
اسرائيل لم تكن فقط موجهه صوب تل ابيب
انما ربما الى ابعد من ذلك ربما تكون
موجهه صوب حيفا او الى الضواحي الجنوبيه
منها لان تدخل المنظومه منظومه مقلاع
داهود جرى حقيقه فوق مدينه تل ابيب اي قب
قبل وصول هذه الصواريخ الى ربما مناطق
ابعد من مدينه تلي ابيب الكبرى وهو ما
استدعى تدخل هذه المنظومه الدفاعيه في
عمليه الاعتراض وهذا يدلل على ان المقاومه
الفلسطينيه ما زالت تملك القدره على
اختيار الزمان واختيار المكان واختيار
المديات التي تستهدف فيها المدن
الاسرائيليه الكبرى وان تدخل اليوم اكثر
من 300 3 ملايين اسرائيلي الى الم لاجئ
والى الغرف المحكمه بعد ان كانت الجبهه
الداخليه التابعه للجيش الاسرائيلي قد
عملت على مدى الاسابيع الماضيه في اعاده
الحياه الى سابق عهدها او طلبت من
الاسرائيليين على الاقل العوده الى سير
حياتهم الطبيعيه مع التقيد بحاله الطوارئ
المفروضه واذ بهذه الدفعه الصاروخيه التي
تستهدف مدينه تل ابيب الكبرى تجبر حوالي 3
ملايين اسرائيلي على الدخول الى الملاجئ
ومن نظر هذا ظهر هذا اليوم الى تطبيق
الدفاع المدني كان يرى بان المنطقه الوسطى
لاسرائيل قد اصطبغت كلها باللون الاحمر
دلاله الى صافرات الانذار التي دوت في
عشرات المدن الاسرائيليه الكبرى حول مدينه
تلي ابيب وعشرات البلدات الاسرائيليه
الصغيره فيما يعرف بالسهل الداخلي لكن
حقيقه بان هذه الضربه الصاروخيه اثارت
كثيرا من التساؤلات وعلامات الاستفهام لدى
كثير من المحللين العسكريين والمراقبين في
اسرائيل ومن بينهم ايضا ضباط وقيادات
سابقين في الجيش الاسرائيلي الذين تساءلوا
عن جدوى العمليه العسكريه الاسرائيليه وما
الذي تفعله القوات الاسرائيليه في داخل
قطاع غزه طالما ان المقاومه الفلسطينيه ما
زالت قادره على توجيه هذه الصواريخ باتجاه
المدن الاسرائيليه الكبرى في وقت تواصل
فيه اسرائيل قصفها الجوي العنيف والبحري
والقصف المدفعي الذي لا يتوقف على مدار
الساعه واحيانا على مدار الدقيقه في دك
مناطقه فلسطينيه بعينها في قطاع غزه
الواضح بان المجتمع الاسرائيلي يتساءل هذه
الاسئله ايضا لكن من ناحيه اخرى محمود نحن
نرى بان المجتمع الاسرائيلي يتلقى نصف
الروايه فقط التي يعطيها له الاعلام
الاسرائيلي من ناحيه والناطق العسكري من
ناحيه اخرى روايه احاديه الجانب روايه
تعبر عن نصف الحقيقه فقط والتي تتحدث عن
انتصارات الجيش الاسرائيلي وما يحققه من
انجازات في قطاع غزه سواء على ما يدعونه
من قتل عشرات المسلحين الفلسطينيين وتدمير
مستودعات الاسلحه والوصول الى منصات
الصواريخ وما الى ذلك فيما يغيبون نصف
الحقيقه الاخرى وهي ما تتعرض له القوات
الاسرائيليه في المواجهه البريه في
الميدان عندما اي تنشر كتائب القسام
وسرايا القدس احيانا ايه مقاطع الفيديو
التي تشير الى استهداف القوات الاسرائيليه
من مسافه سفر وتوقع قتلى وجرحى في صفوف
الجنود الاسرائيليين هذه الصور تغيب عن
الشاشات الاسرائيليه عن شاشات التلفزه عن
الاعلام الاسرائيلي ولا يجري الحديث عنها
حتى من قبل الناطق العسكري الاسرائيلي
لذلك عندما تضرب المدن الاسرائيليه الكبرى
في وقت يقول فيه الجيش الاسرائيلي بانه
يحقق انتصارات هذا يثير كثيرا من
التساؤلات وعلامات الاستفهام لدى المجتمع
الاسرائيلي الذي يتساءل عن اي انجازات وعن
اي انتصارات يتحدث الجيش الاسرائيلي في
وقت ما زالت المدن الاسرائيليه الكبرى
تتعرض فيها الى هذا القصف الشديد في وقت
تعجز فيه المؤسسه العسكريه والجيش
الاسرائيلي عن تحقيق صوره نصر واحده يمكن
ان تعرضها على المجتمع الاسرائيلي ولتقول
هذا هو النصر وهذا هو الانجاز الذي حققه
الجيش الاسرائيلي صفر لا يوجد اي انجاز
هذا حتى
بحسب الخبراء العسكريين والمراقبين في
اسرائيل الذين يقولون بان مجرد قدره
المقاومه الفلسطينيه على توجيه هذه
الصواريخ باتجاه مدينه تلي ابيب الكبرى
وكل ضواحيها الجنوبيه والشرقيه والوصول
الى مطار بن جريون الدولي وكاننا في اول
يوم من من الحرب هذا يدلل على ان حركه
حماس لم ترفع الرايه البيضاء هذا يقوله
خبراء عسكريون اسرائيليون يعني حماس لم
تستسلم وحماس لم ترفع الرايا البيضاء وان
الجيش الاسرائيلي لم ينجز المهمه ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي يتحدث عن عمليات تكتيكيه
وانجازات تكتيكيه هنا وهناك وهذا الامر
ربما يبعده عن تحقيق الهدف الاستراتيجي
الاسمى او الاعلى الذي وضعه الجيش
الاسرائيلي والحكومه الاسرائيليه منذ
اليوم الاول للحرب وهو القضاء على حركه
حماس عسكريا و وسياسيا ويقولون ربما ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي ما زال بعيدا عن تحقيق
هذه الاهداف لانه ما زال يتحدث عن اهداف
تكتيكيه وانجازات تكتيكيه في قطاع غزه
محمود